Jo Now by The Daily wise Matt wsh from
Nashville uh how's the weather Matt I
hear it's a little chilly down there so
we got about 3 Ines of snow and it shut
the whole city down that's the way
that's the way we do it here in the
South so uh it's been it's been an
adventure for sure well it's good to see
you um so much to talk about as always
in your wheelhouse but I want to talk
about this extraordinary story about the
Federal Aviation Administration actively
recruiting workers who suffer severe
intellectual disabilities psychiatric
problems and other mental and physical
conditions under a diversity and
inclusion hiring initiative spelled out
on the agency's website on the face of
it this seems plain ridiculous your
thoughts yeah on the face of it it seems
plain ridiculous I think when you look
deeper it still seems plain ridiculous
now obviously um no one is claiming that
at this point they're going to hire you
know someone who's blind or paralyzed to
actually fly you know a a Delta aircraft
30,000 ft in the air so we're not maybe
we'll get to that point we're not at
that point yet um but the point is that
they have decided this goes back to I
believe it's 2013 an Obama era
initiative by the FAA that they wanted
to diversify the airline industry and uh
and they have a lot of several different
groups that um they wanted to uh
increase their you know participation in
the airline industry and uh those with
disabilities is one of those groups
groups now what you'll hear from people
on the other side of this people that
are you know fans of these kinds of
diversification efforts is that well
yeah they're doing this but they're not
lowering the standards at all in order
to do it that's the claim anyway um and
and it's true that whether it's daa or
any other institution that is putting
Dei into practice and trying to
diversify uh none of them will come out
and say of course none of them are going
to say that we're lowering the standards
but that obviously is what ends up
happening because if you if you had the
standard set a certain place and um and
then you ended up with like a certain
number of let's say white pilots and
then you say well we don't want that
many white Pilots so we want to get more
of other types of people in there well
what do you have to do with the
standards uh you end up lowering them
and that's exactly exactly what happens
I mean I saw that the the new coach um
in the NFL has replaced bill bich of the
Patriots and he's immed mediately come
out and played the race card and
basically saying if you don't see color
you don't understand racism and so on uh
other black coaches in the NFL have
taken a very different View and said all
they want to see is football and players
they don't care about what color they
are and it struck me is sort of a
bizarre stance to take because the vast
majority of players example in the NFL
are black I think nearly
70% what did you make of that when you
heard it
well I think if you are you know that if
we're getting to the point where we can
find anti-black racism in the NFL well
then then just the the concept means
nothing anymore as you point out I think
it's like 70 to 80% of players in the
NFL are black uh the NFL if you if you
take all the different positions on the
field and on the sidelines it is you
know black people are vastly over
represented when you compare them to the
13% of the overall population
um so if we're looking for racism even
there then uh then then it's just the
entire concept is is totally meaningless
uh and in particular this idea that
black head coaches are are being
targeted for racism of course I'm not
the first person to point this out but
okay if a if a lack of NFL of black NFL
head coaches is a result of racism then
how do you explain a lack of say white
defensive backs on the field there's
basically none at this point and are
they being targeted for racism so it
just it just doesn't make any sense yeah
I mean 60% of Americans I think in the
most recent poll I saw are white and yet
they're not represented by 60% white
players in NFL or the NBA or most
American Sports but nobody nobody
complains about that no one says well
hang on that's racist no one would think
that way the other way around and I
admire these uh black coaches in the NFL
whove stood up and went no of course
it's ridiculous it's irrelevant All We
Care is how good the player is or how
good the coach is or how good the
executives
are yeah and that's and and by the way
the reason why people don't complain the
other way is that of course we know that
diversify diversity and inclusion all
these phrases this is coded language and
what it really means is we have to make
these things less white but nobody wants
to come out and say that that's one of
the reasons why you hear you'll often
hear them refer to um not only diverse
groups but they'll talk about diverse
people we need we need a more diverse
person in this role but how how could a
person individually be diverse doesn't
make any sense well then you understand
what they're really saying is we want a
non-white person they just don't want to
come out and say that I think another
important point that you brought up is
that you know if we are obsessed with
representation if it is very important
that every group be exactly represented
in every industry that we look at and I
don't agree that that is important I
think that's a that's a an unworkable
unten unsustainable goal that makes no
sense and it's totally arbitrary but
this is what representation would mean
representation would mean that you have
whatever your percentage is in the
overall population that's what you have
in this industry um but then you find
out that that's not good enough for the
representation police which is which is
interesting right exactly let's take a
short break Matt I want to come back and
talk about the daily wise brilliant new
comedy movie lady Ballers which the
title may give people a clue about what
issue this is about but of course it
relates to this ongoing furor around
trans athletes in women's
sport welcome back to on sensed from New
York was a lot colder than it looked in
that live shop Matt wal is still with me
uh Matt lady Ballers is the brilliant
new movie from you guys at Daily W let's
take a look at a little
clip
let's cut to the chase I know you're not
a woman hey you don't know how he
identifies if you can beat though what
do you know about the US opens for the
global games you want us to compete as
women $5,000 prizes my lover says you're
a great coach back in the day J this is
the way the world is now my 8-year-old
daughter told me all about it so a guy
can become a girl with no physical
changes at all oh that's called ginger
fluid
I mean it's a brilliant idea um first of
all why did you make
it well I I can't take credit for making
the movie or writing or anything like
that I I play a you know relatively
small role in the film and uh I think my
my entire role is really just it's
really just me being trolled by the
director of the film is also CEO of the
company Jeremy boring where he decided
to write a role for me where I am the
exact opposite of who I am in real life
just to make me as uncomfortable as
possible so I'm playing this um this
kind of left-wing hippie character who's
also a big a big hugger you know I'm I'm
big into hugging people in the movie um
but I think the reason why the movie
exists is pretty simple number one it's
a really funny idea and it's also it's
it's it's the kind of it's kind of movie
that needs to exist like this this whole
concept of men competing against women
in women's sports is absurd it's it's
ridiculous it is it's laughable and um
you know if this kind of thing was was
happening 25 years ago there would
probably be a comedy like this made
about it but these days yes well they
don't really make comedies anymore at
all but they certainly aren going to
make a comedy making fun of this so so
uh we did and the truth is that it it
really takes the whole argument on the
protrans aete side to its logical
conclusion you know I've always when
I've interviewed politicians who don't
want to uh speak common sense about this
I say well okay so if you have Limitless
self-identity and anyone can say I'm now
female what happens if Usain Bolt or
Floyd Mayweather decide they want to be
a woman could would you be happier than
competing against biological females in
women's sport and they always have to
say yes and it's always completely
Preposterous Floyd May Mayweather would
kill women in a ring and Usain Bolt
would win the 100 meters women's Olympic
final by about 99 m i mean it's an
absurdity which this film brilliantly
Lampoons but it's actually true
it is true which is why you don't have
to work that hard to make fun of it you
don't even have to exaggerate that much
uh you know this is one of the things
actually maybe it makes satire difficult
these days is that the reality itself is
so ridiculous that it's usually in
satire you're taking something uh you're
taking the logic to an extreme extent to
show how ridiculous it is but in this
case we you know all you're doing is
this is what's actually happening in
real life and I think that what you said
there there is key though you said that
they that they have to you we're talking
to someone who supports men and women
sports they they they they have to they
have to go along with it they have to
agree to whatever absurd scenario you
throw at them and they really do they
have to um but I don't think they
actually believe it I think that the
number of people who really deep down
believe that it's fair and right for
biological males compete against females
in sports I mean the number of people is
is vanishingly small but on the left
they basically box themselves into a
corner and so they have to defend this
and we should make them defend it whilst
simultaneously trying to pretend that
they are pro women's rights I mean
that's the absurdity because of course
it's women's rights to fairness and
equality that are being dismantled at
this alar of virtue signaling
nonsense and and there are also the
people that have claimed in the past to
care so much about about maintaining
women's sports that's what Title 9 was
supposed to be about you know I people
often accuse me on the left they'll say
that they'll say well you don't even
care about women's sports that much
you're just pretending I never said that
I I don't I don't wake up in the morning
uh worrying about women's sports I don't
I don't watch women's sports I I so in
that sense yeah I don't I don't care
about it in that sense but I do care
about just what's right I care about
what's logical what makes sense um I
care about the kids that are involved in
these Sports and protecting them so uh
yeah it but if if you if you do pretend
that this is something that's very
important to you then uh the question is
why why AR you there taking up this
right I mean I care because I have a
12-year-old daughter who's quite sporty
and I don't want her to if she was to
suddenly be very successful at some
sport in women's sport I don't want to
have her have a dream killed or a place
in a team or you know even you see it at
Olympic level you see women being
deprived of an Olympic place a coveted
glorious Olympic place by a biological
male that that's just not right right
it's not fair it's not right it's not
equal it's none of those
things and you're also I I also would
not want my daughter I wouldn't want her
athletic opportunities taken from her if
she decided to get into sports I don't
want her to be in a position where she
has to go along with something that is a
total farce like that it's just it's
wrong to put anybody especially kids the
matter what the context is to put them
in a position where they have to uh
where they feel pressured to go along
with something like that and especially
when the pressure is coming from adults
I mean it's one thing when you deal with
peer pressure as a kid from other kids
but in this case it's the adults that
are using their Authority and their
power to uh Usher you along in this
direction I think it's just utterly
ridiculous now I want to put two
pictures up on the screen for our
audience these are both Calvin Klein uh
underwear uh commercials one Stars a
female model uh the other one Stars the
Bear's uh actor Jeremy Allen White and
what is comical about this is that they
both reveal a lot of Flesh in fact the
Man reveals more flesh than the woman
the the female one has been censored by
the advertising standard Authority
because it's overtly sexual but the
other one is apparently absolutely fine
I've seen this hypocrisy a double
standard on these kind of things for
decades Matt right it's absurd isn't
it it is totally absurd I I for for that
one it's hard for me to even understand
I mean usually when you have an
absurdity like this you can understand
what what logic they're going for even
if it doesn't really make sense
ultimately but in that case I'm not even
sure exactly
what what would their argument be
apparently the argument was that the the
ad involving FKA twig the models
physical features rather than the
clothing uh presented a stereotypical
sexual object he has less clothes on
than she
does yeah it it it doesn't make any
sense but when you're when you're
talking about things like decency and
modesty and and that and that's an
important conversation to have but I
think in our culture we don't have a
very
coherent notion of what that even is or
how to apply it and that's how you end
up with confused situations ridiculous
Matt we've run out of time it's always
great to catch up with you I hope it
warms up down there and hope to catch up
with you again soon thank you very
much